[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt es mal wieder einen
cheesecake ich habe ja schon einige
cheesecake rezepte auf einem kanal aber
käsekuchen geht halt immer vor allem
gibt es so viele abwandlungen und
variationen die man einfach alle mal
ausprobiert haben sollte ich mache ganz
geld das das sehr crème brulée und
deswegen mache ich heute einen crème
brulée cheesecake und der kiesweg ist
wirklich super einfach ihr braucht
wirklich nur wenige zutaten und die habe
ich meistens auch immer da
ich mache zuerst einmal den boden und
den mache ich aus butter und keksen so
muss man nämlich keinen teig herstellen
für den boden verwende ich 125 gramm
butter 50 gramm mandeln 150 gramm
löffelbiskuits und in abrede einer
unbehandelten orange nämlich zuerst
einmal die butter die kommt hier in
einen topf und da kann ich sie kurz
schmelzen und in der zwischenzeit und
einfach schon mal die mandeln und die
löffel bis zu verkleinern
ich nehme immer gerne ganze mandeln gibt
sie nämlich einfach ein bisschen
aromatischer als bereits gemahlene
mandeln
und jetzt einfach noch die löffel bist
wird rein nach und nach der kleidung
jetzt die butter geschmolzen und die
kekse und mandeln sind zwar kleiner die
kann ich jetzt verrühren und hier auch
noch ein bisschen orangen abrieb dazu
geben
jetzt einfach schön verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt kommt diese keks master in meinen
vorbereiteten backing und da drücke ich
die keks masse jetzt am boden fest das
heißt einfach schön verteilen und dann
entweder mit den händen mit einem glas
oder zum beispiel mit der burger presse
richtig schön fest und platt drücken
eine burger presse geht hat echt am
besten wo ist da
die berker und torten presse so wird sie
nicht nur zur grillzeit genutzt damit
kann ich den boden bereits vor packung
und den derzeit schon mal die creme
zusammen
für die creme verwende ich 500 gramm
frischkäse im doppel rahmen stufe 400
gramm sahne 140 gramm zucker einen
teelöffel stärke etwas vanille extrakt
eine prise tonkabohne vier eier und 2
eigelbe nämlich jetzt den frischkäse und
stieß auch wichtig dass es ein doktor am
frischkäse ist damit der cheesecake
schön cremig wird und erst mal ganz kurz
geschmeidig rühren aber nicht auf
höchster stufe denn ich möchte jetzt
hier keine luft einschlagen sondern das
ganze nur cremig rühren
deswegen nur bei niedriger stufe langsam
die sache dazu
[Applaus]
dann von selbst so geheim die stärke
dann das vanille extrakt nicht schüttelt
immer vorher damit sich dieser vanille
warmen immer schön verteilen
das vanillemark ich habe ich noch
tonkabohne das ein ganz ganz tolles
gewürz davon nur eine ganz kleine prise
noch ein bisschen branche abrieb an der
reihe aber das ist schlimm was im boden
ist der torte kann hier der creme nicht
schaden
und jetzt einfach langsam nach und nach
die eier dazugeben und kurz mit
einbringen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fertig jetzt warte ich einfach auf den
cheesecake boden gehen nachricht dann
auch ganz kurz in der form abkühlen und
dann fühle ich das schon rein und dann
kann der cheesecake gebacken werden und
derzeit renne ich auch es ist jetzt
geboten ein bisschen abgekühlt
jetzt kommt hier die creme drauf und
bisher läuft was raus so schlimm
ihr könnt auch den teig vorher gern in
baku 1 schlagen also den parkring und
jetzt ihren vorheizen backofen stellen
etwa 15 minuten bei 150 grad weiter
backen dann den ofen zurückstellen und
fertig backen
[Musik]
der check ist gebacken und ich habe ihn
im backofen ein bisschen abkühlen lassen
so etwa eine stunde dann raus genommen
auf frauen temperatur abkühlen lassen
und dann den kühlschrank gepackt ich
werde jetzt mal die frucht soße
zubereiten und hier könnt ihr gerne
himbeer fruchtlose machen
heidelbeeren erdbeeren alles was ihr
möchtet gerne auch gefrorene früchte
ich mache jetzt ein bisschen eine
exotische frucht ich nehme jetzt
passionsfrucht und mango für die
fruchtige soßen verwende ich hier
maracuja also passionsfrucht ich habe
eine reife mango etwas vanille extrakt
zitronensaft und 580 gramm gelierzucker
das ist der drei plus eins zucker ich
habe sie die pensions- früchte und diese
immer recht gut und schön reif wenn sie
außen richtig runzlig sind also diese
zwei hier die sind noch ein bisschen zu
fest und deswegen sollte jetzt auch auf
die dürfen gerne in meinem
vorratsschrank noch ein bisschen ruhe
und ich nehme sie die reifen und im
prinzip entscheidet jetzt selbst möchte
ich jetzt mit maracuja oder mango und
ich brauche einfach insgesamt 500 gramm
frucht hier aufschneiden und dann
einfach auslöffeln
und dann gebe ich das ziel direkt in den
topf und wiechs auch direkt mit ab damit
ich eben auch die perfekte menge habe
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier ungefähr 150 gramm
akoya und den rest völlig mit der mango
die mango ist auch reif aber nicht
überreif da schneide ich jetzt hier
rechts und links vom kern war es weg die
setzt sich dann hier ein hohes gefäß an
und kann sich so ganz einfach stehlen
noch einfacher geht es wenn sie ein
bisschen reifer ist aber es gibt auch so
und ansonsten können auch einfach im
sparschäler nehmen und die mango ganz
normal schälen und die schneide ich
jetzt groß und setzt sie dann gar nicht
konkurrieren
[Musik]
da noch ein bisschen kraft dazu unschön
fein pürieren
die übrige mango also ich hier habe ich
noch den großen kern das knappe ja auch
später
jetzt kommt alles hier in den topf gerne
mit ein bisschen meinl extrakt
aromatisieren den gelierzucker rein
manchmal glaube ich doch nur die hälfte
weil das mango curry doch relativ fest
ist dann aufkochen lassen weil ich spüre
hier noch ein bisschen mit wasser aus
dann kann ich nämlich auch den
restlichen zucker dazugeben
jetzt saß die sauce aufkochen und dann
bei geringer hitze drei bis vier minuten
einkochen
ich hole jetzt mal einen kuchen aus der
form heraus der sich schön kühl und
packt ihn kuchen auf jeden fall den bug
ob ihr ein denn die füllung ist wirklich
sehr sehr flüssig und das problem ist
einfach wenn man diese logik boden hat
dann geht er immer so ein bisschen
zusammen der tortenring ist aber größer
natürlich tritt in die flüssigkeit aus
jetzt nicht weiter schlimm wir können
das hier auch weg essen
aber es ist schade um die füllung jetzt
kommt die zucker kruste dafür nehmen sie
jetzt einfach braunen zucker oder auch
normalen zucker da kommt jetzt hier oben
drauf
und wenn ihnen ins lange habt nehmt ihr
den falls nicht könnt ihr natürlich auch
den kuchen es einfach bei grill stufe in
den backofen stellen ganz weit oben
damit der grill wirklich so kurz wie
möglich den kuchen erwärmt und dann
einfach auf höchster stufe kurz grill
bis das karamell gebildet ist ansonsten
15 umgehen
[Musik]
murat kaum crème brulée das magst du
guckst tschuldigung da waren hocker aber
der wandel für dich da war für ella
richtig schöne kruste
diese creme brulée torte mit krempe
cheesecake also unten cremig und oben
schön knackig okay und weil du so gerne
mag das zuckerstück ich glaube nicht
dass es irgendjemand gibt die creme
brulée nicht kennt oder gezeichnet und
ja aber vielleicht gibt es menschen die
es nicht gegessen haben das kann ich mir
schon vorstellen und zwar als hoch gegen
kontrast marco ja weil ich so gerne mag
hier marco es ging ja ich glaube ich
hätte etwas rotes grammer ich rote
früchte auch fotos immer schöner finde
aber maracuja ich denke es geht um eine
geschmackliche foto ich weiß ich denke
aber schon im voraus und im geschmack
natürlich so okay ich denke wenn das mir
geben eigentlich bin schon die marokko
erreichen wenn er da ist aber in dem
abschnitt stream von die oder so
okay ich habe am maracuja mango
eingekocht mit marmelade hammer schmeckt
richtig genial ergebnis ist ein
politiker oder keinen fall denn
eigentlich ist also das atomar ne
zeitlang diese bündelung davon zweites
herz zur donath und costa krone und das
ist crème brulée cheesecake fleißig sein
und muss ich sagen das war eine gute
wahl mit dem akoya das hat noch einen
anderen geschmack richtig bruch die ich
dann ist karamell hammer das freut nicht
nur ihn gefallen ich glaube das ist ein
ganz wenige zutaten mach das bitte nach
weil das ist echter brecher wirklich das
hat er bestimmt auch viele parking joe
wir was noch wichtig ist
falls ihr zum beispiel am vortag schon
den cheesecake zubereiten wollte die
zuckerschicht die würde
wirklich erst kurz vor verzehr machen
wenn ich starte nämlich mit kuchen
glocke darauf gebe kann es passieren
dass einfach die zuckerschicht weich
wird durch die feuchtigkeit und dann
habt ihr diesen knack nicht mehr drin
also wirklich dann kurz vor dem
servieren einfachzucker drauf flambieren
meine sieht halt auch super spektakulär
außerdem flambieren kommt und danach
einfach nicht mehr abdecken aber
unbedingt freut mich das macht mir
freude wenn dir das schmeckt das ist
unfair geht durch den gleichen jungs
aber zeigen ja ich habe auch noch mehr
maracuja und das rezept findet ihr auch
sallys - brachte ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen und vielleicht
finden wir ja gemeinsam noch weitere
verbindungen von desserts oder wir
können ja auch noch mal was neues sind
die kommentare vielleicht habt ihr coole
ideen
ihr könnt mir auch das ganze als
challenge machen also wirklich
reinschreiben jene idee da eine idee
macht mal was verrücktes raus und dann
mache ich gerne verrückte ideen und
vielleicht schmeckt vielleicht nicht
kann man ausprobieren aber durch
also viel spaß und nachhaken bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss macht's gut macht's
besser du siehst fertig aus ich glaube
das hat mein papa schränke auf
das war echt furchtbar ich gesagt gut
ihr nicht also mit papa zusammen möbel
aufbauen sagt macht nichts wirklich ich
hätte also da hast du in den mann seit
30 jahren da haben wir es immer ist
bleiben schrauben übrig und der teils im
übrigen ja weil er nicht noch keine
hersteller eine schraube zu viel rein
machen also wenn ich schraube übrig
bleibt am asphalt schlimmer ist ein papa
schon 10.000 mal aber da bin ich noch
nicht da wo wir nicht treffen und dass
es nicht machen
der baut auch nicht mehr war nicht der
nimmt gleich den plan in die hand nehmen
und sagte so und so neue märkte glauben
dass er sehr viel ihren zweck oder
portrait ich weiß war da sagt sind zu
wenig vielleicht hat es noch packen ja
genau welche vergessen sie ganz ehrlich
löcher vergessen die möbelbauer aber
schrauben haben sie zuviel dabei hat es
am falsch rum und dann ist noch halt auf
der anderen seite genau das hat er
gemacht ehrlich der kunden hat link oben
löschen gehabt mir egal ist ein schrank
ich hab gesagt mach es nicht dass ich
bin da raus aber erstmal das kaputt und
dann richtet das aber es geht halt nicht
immer so gut aus
[Musik]